[Musique]
partout où je vais je vois son visage il
me manque friend with me manque aussi je
ne pense pas que tony aurait fait ce
qu'il a fait s'il n'avait pas été
convaincu que tu allais prendre la
relève
c'est toi qui remplace iron man ou quoi
oh non pas le temps je suis trop occupé
à faire votre boulot quoi
non je rigole frugal vous assurez mais
faut continuer comme ça parce que je
pars en vacances
[Musique]
attention les curiaces apte à jouer
j'ai pas trop envie de parler à nicolet
répond pourquoi parce que si tu lui
parles pas je vais devoir le faire et
jean luc henry a balancé d'écurie sur la
messagerie j'ai une urgence la personne
ne s'applique pas à l'ena salut ouais on
parlait du voyage et suit en direct de
la place saint marc
je crois que j'aime bien ça me rappelle
mon premier bout crurent tu n'est
vraiment pas facile à joindre spider man
[Musique]
je te présente monsieur beck qui aurait
sa place dans mon monde
votre monde qu'est né sur la terre mais
pas la nôtre l'effacement a créé une
faille dans notre dimension
vous confirmez kir multivers nous avons
une mission et tu viens avec nous je
suis sûr que vous pouvez trouver
quelqu'un d'autre
pourquoi pas tort or dimension captain
marvel indisponibles
je fais que la petite araignée sympa du
quartier oui tu parles tu reviennes
l'espace
tu veux quoi peter je veux reprendre mon
voyage avec la fille que j'aime et lui
dire ce que je ressens
mg je suis spider man non pas du tout
c'est franchement super évident la
raison qui n'est peut-être pas prêt mais
c'est ma responsabilité
sauver le monde exige des sacrifices
parfois les gens meurent
j'ai toujours le sentiment de mettre mes
amis en danger le monde a besoin d'un
nouvel iron man est ce que tu vas
assumer
soit vous évacuez on va prendre le jet
vous êtes si vous passez avec spider man
poussé pour spiderman pose avec celui
d'un débat pour spiderman plombé
[Musique]